Đó thì công chương viên chức đừng nghỉ 2 ngày cho quy định dịp lệ cuốc khánh của ngày 1.000 và 1 ngày liên kể trước
Là ngày 1 một thành chính, cả nước cũng thực hiện hoảng đổi từ ngày 2.2 ngày 3.30, sang làm buồn vào ngày 1.000, là thứ bẩy ngày 2.000, như vậy là cuộc với ngày 1.000 và ngày lệ, cả 1 công chức đừng nghỉ 5 ngày liên tiếp trong 10 ngày
Bớn đã cũng khu vực xuân nghiệp dịp lệ cuốc khánh sẽ được lì thứ 2 ngày 1.000 và lợi trọng nghiệm 1 trong 2 ngày
Là thứ 3 ngày 1 một thành chính hoặc là thứ 5 ngày 1.000, cả đơn vị, cựo khoảng 1 chiên sắp xế các bộ phần ứng chức theo đệng
Và làm việc hợp lý để giải quyết công việc liên tục, bởi đầm công các phục bộ nha xanh trong đó lưu ý cực cả bộ công chức ứng chức
Sự li những công việc đồ xuất bất ngờ có thể xảy ra trong thời gian nghỉ lệ tế theo quy định
Bởi đỏ thông báo của bộ nội vụ nưu giáo, các bộ cơ quan địa phương của kế hoạch miệng pháp của thế, phù hợp quyền kích cơ sáng nghiệp nâng vị tổ chức khánh nhân tích cụp chủ đỏ
Chỉnh Khai thực hiện các bạn pháp phát triển sản xuất hiện sói nghe có đồng kinh tây xã hội, mà đầm công tổ hàng ngoài sịch vụ ồn định giả cả thị trường
Họ phần thu dậy tăng trường tình tế, thực hiện tích kịp trong lãng vị trong thời gian chức trong và sau dịp lệ của khánh nâng hành hình cùng chăm sóng
Giới nghe phải thông báo phương ngán nghỉ lệ của khánh nâng trong người lợ động, trước khi thực hiện in hết là 3 mươi ngày, bộ nâng vụ cũng khuyên kinh người sử dụng lợ động áp dụng thời gian nghỉ lệ của khánh nâng lợ động, nhiều phương ngán đồn vời công chức phía trước, đồng thời khuyên thiết những thuật thận có lợi hơn trong người lợi động